well love is in the air not only is the
little vegas chapel celebrating its
expansion it's also kicking off the
grand opening with a very special
ceremony marrier carolyn goodman is set
to officiate the commitment ceremony
between our friend frank marino and his
partner alex schechter we're so happy
for you guys thank you um and i'm well i
i just i can't talk to you guys without
talking about these outfits i am
obsessed you guys are bringing the
sparkle this is a celebration right
that's right
all right let's get right usually
i know but you guys coordinated today i
got the black you know i can be a
bridesmaid i'm volunteering myself you
guys okay
so let's talk about this congratulations
to you guys what made you decide to take
part in all of this
well
we got asked to be honest and it was
about the chapel and america uh mayor
goodman doing her first ever
gay ceremony so she's like who better to
ask than frank and alex we've known them
for years and we've been together for
years so it was like at about time you
know oh my gosh this is so exciting and
what made you guys decide to take the
leap you've been together for so long
and here you go almost 30 years yes and
um
and it's a commitment ceremony you know
i do really want to have a wedding one
day but if i do a wedding it's going to
be really big of course so this is just
you know something we can do now during
gay pride month everything just fit in a
little square and since it was so easy
to do we said to each other let's just
do it it'll be something nice and you
know we're so happy for you guys and
what does it mean to have the support
from the community i feel like las vegas
really rallies together during this
month and all throughout the year but
especially during pride month and i've
always had it i'll say i've always had
the support of the gay community and i'm
here almost 40 years now so i used to
say thank you to all you guys for that
guys and girls but uh
you've had it too you've had a lot of
support from them
between all the shows that i have and
everything they always come out and
support we invite them to every event
and it's just it is sort of a family you
know in vegas it's the big little city
yeah and you guys are seriously this
dynamic duo there's nothing you two
can't conquer together and i know the
chapel is probably just so excited to
have you guys representing them tell us
a little bit about the revamp of this
chapel and what people can expect so
they've added a whole new chapel to um
their existing one it's a brand new room
it's a lot more modern like the one that
they have now currently has a lot of
wood and it's a little bit more more
rustic and this is very sleek and modern
so they can give the option to the to
the customers what they want you know
yeah so a little something for everyone
and it's just fun to get married in
vegas no matter what but now these
chapels are like continuing to take it
to the next level and you're having all
the trouble with the elvises yes but in
ours he's got thunder from down under
being his groom's man
i have the showgirls from the diva
legend show that i'm doing at the
tropicana so it's going to be a true las
vegas wedding with all that going on and
you have jillian lopez as your flower
girl mate yeah no flowers on i'm just
inviting myself to be part of the
wedding because i'm so happy for you
guys and you just have so much going on
so really quickly i want to touch on you
have a new show you've got all your
stuff where can we see you guys out and
about in the city okay oh god he's got
shows there's stratosphere he's got
struggles there's an excalibur
he's got long lists i'm easy i'm just at
the tropicana every night at divas and
we have a big thing coming up with that
too for gay pride so gosh look out for
that we're doing something at the end of
the month to close up gay pride so
excited about the legend stuff
my diva brunches at westgate are going
really good yes i've heard next year the
secret is the big news i am bringing
divas back with the female impersonators
i get so many people asking that i
finally gave in and we're gonna do it
and you're doing it well you guys we
absolutely love you congratulations on
this we can't wait to continue to
celebrate you we're so excited about the
little chapel and you guys look great
and um i'll see you at the wedding like
i said i'm inserting myself you guys are
awesome thank you so much for being here